[Music]
[Applause]
I have to ask right off the bat what do
you have does it I have to ask about the
sunglasses what's with the science um I
have just started wearing women's
sunglasses it's a real conversation
started yeah it is that yeah a lot of
people love it I can see by the name
there Kim Jong Il Brandi wearing women's
sunglasses people come up and no they
approach me differently and yes it's
just a fun way to walk into a room it
looks fantastic
but you're indoors now oh oh wait yeah
okay yeah there you go
none of those I'm gonna put these right
here in a spot cuz they're not what Andy
to try to take them yeah stale babies
lady mom you go ahead and talk to him
I'll be fine
now well I saw you not too long ago you
you were awarded
- let me - hang on to those thank you I
appreciate you - you've got you sold me
I'm gonna do
Mark Twain Award you were awarded the
prestigious Mark Twain Award I I flew in
to wash things I wanted to be there for
a lot of your friends did you're very
fortunate very fortunate being my
present yes to be near you I was so
lucky while we're there what were there
you told me that you visited the Oval
Office I did and a lot of people get to
see the Oval Office when you went the
president was there president was
actually there and and handed me the
Mark Twain bust in a it's a special
award for Mark Twain and you know in
kind of a ceremonial way and you know
amazing to kind of actually be there
with the president and then we we set
our lows you take the photos you get a
little seven minute tour try not to bump
into anything or break anything and then
as we're leaving we're walking out the
hallway thank you so much sir and I just
hear the president yelling hey we'll hey
hey well
like uh yes yes you are you left your
bust oh you left you actually yeah yeah
the trophy yeah I'm so nervous I left
the trophy on his desk
yeah that's nice he purrs dance yes and
you you left your you left your bus
uh-huh and I I said well you can you can
have it if you want I'd like to have
your own but I missed the comedy
opportunity because when he yelled my
name I should have just said not now
never yell my name what is it that would
have been great you didn't have the
nerves I thought of it later but thought
of it later I thought of it right now
actually you weren't wearing ladies
sunglasses whoa isn't if I had the
composure you have when you wear women
someday I would have been on my comedy
toe exactly speaking of high honor you
were King Bacchus in the Mardi Gras
parade in Bacchus parade in the Box one
of his many Mardi Gras parades yes I was
we have I believe this is a photo of you
that's right look and say that's right
before the seizure look at that guy that
guy is so happy he thinks he rules a
foreign land oh yes beads for all did
that go to your head double chins for
all
[Laughter]
look at his double chin
[Laughter]
[Applause]